et conditions de travail sont très
difficiles pour les libéraux pour les
hospitaliers aussi nous en tant
qu'infirmier libéral on n'a pas de
matériel on n'a pas de solution hydro
alcoolique c'est mes patients qui
m'appellent pour me dire moi j'ai des
masques je peux vous aider
plusieurs formats simon ri au nez en me
disant mais de quel stop de l'état vous
parlait jeudi mais les stocks de l'état
ils doivent délivrer des masques ya
quatre cinq jours la pharmacie a reçu
cinq boîtes de masques adultes dans le
bâtiment il ya sept médecins et cinq
infirmières
non on va avoir beaucoup de difficultés
pour faire face aux cas les plus graves
on va manquer de lits de réanimation on
va manquer de matériel
on va manquer de respirateurs je sais
qu'on va disposer de entre 60 et 90 lits
pour toute l'île on n'a pas souvent dos
au robinet
donc le lavage des mains est très
difficile on se lave les mains avec des
bouteilles dans des bassines on lave nos
passions dans les mêmes conditions on a
de plus en plus de patients qui nous
disent ben ne vient pas ne vient pas ne
vient pas on est obligé de dire à nos
patients bah écoutes je vais te faire la
toilette que ce matin cet après midi je
viendrai pas on va diminuer les soins on
va diminuer nos visites et on a des
patients qui ne disent ben on va se
débrouiller on vient plus ils ont peur